step right up and behold one of the
unexplained mysteries of the universe is
he man
or beast guillermo you had me from
minute one in this film i was completely
gripped but shape of water i stopped
eating fish and now i'm not gonna eat
chicken anymore so i don't know what
you've done tonight
dietary restrictions
fire frustrations i'm familiar with that
so you have said that making this film
really uh expanded and changed who you
said you'll never make a film this way
you know it the same way again because
of this experience and that it revealed
things to you that you didn't even know
as a filmmaker despite how many films
you've made can you talk about that and
how that why that was
yes i mean look
normally what i try to create is a
playground for the actors but i have a
very very precise notion where the scene
will go and
i started to listen
to the movie more
rather than making the movie do what i
wanted and and this came partially from
the fact that on the screen you had an
acting prize fight every day
you had william the fall and bradley
cooper you had caitlyn chet and bradley
cooper you know you had richard jenkins
rooney mara it was like a
like a fantastic
master lesson on on things happening
and i had to keep my camera observant
and active and vigilant of them
rather than tell them you go here you go
here
we would find the scene
as it talked to us and the camera
adjusted accordingly and that was a
life-changing thing because we were all
looking for the truth
how can i make this movie that happens
in the past be about right now
thematically of course truth lies
selling the illusion which we all live
with every day now but how do we make it
living
not feel like a play in a prestigious
production but make it feel like a like
a real thing with characters going at it
so one of the biggest themes of this
film and especially through bradley's
character is a person finding out who
they truly are
so
was this a bit of a mirror did you find
out who you truly are as a director and
if so who is guillermo the director now
as a result of this film well i think
you find it on every film you find on
every film i think look
i i think all of us every single person
gets a moment or two of revelation in
their lives
or where they see themselves it can be
pleasant or it can be completely
unpleasant depending on the moment and i
thought i think every time you go to a
movie you're building a a mirror in a
strange way and you learn about yourself
there's a lot of mirrors in this film i
noticed oh yeah very much on purpose yes
yeah i thought so and the chicken of the
in the room service i noticed that too
can you can you
can you talk just very briefly about
um i know you have pinocchio coming out
next year
how did this in film inform that one at
all and what can we expect with that
world as a result in creating that
character
you know it's funny you should ask
because they do have a parallels
uh obviously pinocchio has a big section
in a carnival
and uh
there's
strange little echoes between the two
and pinocchio
deals with
a different thematic pinocchio is about
what makes a human a human
and what makes a human a puppet
or a puppet a human because it's said
during the rise of mussolini in fascist
italy so
it's it's a really interesting
thematic exercise that one
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
a couple of years ago i don't know if
you remember saying this you said when
are they going to make a circus movie
i'm ready
i don't know if you knew about this film
already this is obviously a carnival
step right up i love that you got to say
that was it everything as an actor you
hoped and dreamed it would be
um you know you always
you always got to be careful about
expectations when you go into things but
i will say that
i remember going to carnivals as a kid
because i grew up in the midwest
in a time where those those things still
came through town even like the ten and
ones the side shows the pickled punks
the
uh
you know the crazy stuff i remember that
and particularly the people that work
the carnival were always very darkly
romantic
characters to me scary but the fantasy
of running off with them was always very
strong so
uh now uh
and then at an a at my age now i'm able
to do that and that was cool so as a kid
what was the favorite act or what would
like if you actually did a circus movie
what would you want to who which
character would you want i know exactly
i
i would like to do um you know the story
of the uh
wallendas you know they're trapeze
artists
yeah wire work you like some wire work
which i'll get to i do i do it and i you
know i'm not sure i could do it
um do the trapeze stuff
you know with the proper training but i
might be able to you know to be kind of
the elder statesman of the trapeze
family that that would be a very cool
role
uh guillermo
landes story there you go we've put it
out in the universe
uh let's talk about guillermo your first
time working with him as a director
uh and i know he really created that
carnival for you guys to live in
but can you talk about he said it
changed him as a director making this
movie and he really let the camera pour
over you guys and and didn't call cut
can you talk about that experience
yeah
he did give us a very complete world
that carnival could almost have
functioned we could have almost uh
you know charged admission and invited
people there i mean things really work
there was such incredible detail it was
so beautiful um
so he gave us a beautiful world to play
in gave us a very strong script that he
wrote with kim and uh
but once we got there he was also very
loose
and
bradley uh working with guillermo they
were very tight and they had a good
rhythm going and by the time i came into
the movie because they shot the second
part first and then there was a break
for covid and then they went back to do
the carnival part
when i came in they were very loose so
of course we would shoot the scripted
stuff but how we would get into that
stuff and how we would get out of that
we often played around with so some of
the connective tissue we really um got
to play around and
uh as as well prepared as guillermo is
he's also gets in a place sees what's
going on and is very loose and lets you
play so that's that's a great um
place to be
as an actor i love him um speaking of
wire work there's a spider woman in this
movie
spider-man
there was a little little shot of
spider-man
how was it going backwards spider-woman
was my wife in the movie
it wasn't clear just because it's a it's
a lot of story there so my god
i wish i had more than four minutes or
five minutes with you but inhabiting
that world again going back to the
spider-man world you're a very busy
actor your future looks bright um how
was it going back into that world and
also you're teaming up with robert
eggers again can you just sort of like
talk about both of those
um sure i mean i
i've been lucky to be doing a lot of
stuff lately and a lot of stuff that i
love and i always love
you know i come from the theater and
it's in the theater that i worked at was
was true company so sometimes we
performed
the same piece
over 20 years i i was with this company
for like
almost 30 years and we would tour a lot
internationally and sometimes we'd bring
back pieces so it's nice to visit
the same roles again visit same
territory down down the line uh
revisit things that's the nature of
theater also um
so similarly i like going back and
working with people that i've had good
experiences with or working in
situations that i've had good
experiences with this time you can go
deeper or you can do something different
i you
you have a shorthand already uh you have
an understanding you have a trust it's
it's a big leg up
where when you
work from zero that can be great too but
you've got to
separate all those things before you can
really get down to it but sometimes when
you have a good rapport with a director
or with a
material
you you you're much more flexible you're
much more free and you can really fly
the monologue in this movie that you
have about the geek really sets up the
ending as an actor how juicy was that
for you
well it's it's it's a story basically
and i remember that was the first thing
we shot that was the first my first day
um
it's a beautifully written uh
story and uh it's an interesting story
and full of
uh
you're not quite sure how he feels about
this he's kind of excited to share it
but also
uh he's not gloating he doesn't exactly
enjoy this it's kind of an expression of
a very dark view of the world as well so
it's complicated emotionally but i think
as far as actually performing it the
most important thing was basically tell
the story to bradley
that bradley character and just make it
clear and kind of gauge how he was
feeling about what i was telling him
because some some aspects of it are a
little shocking so that that that was
the play that was the play
are you in contact with the beyond well
we've had our share of snake charmers in
the past
we deal with them you are reuniting with
guillermo del toro uh in this film
um
first of all he has said that it really
changed him as a director working on
this film did you feel that difference
from this and shape of water and what is
it about guillermo that he always wants
you to freeze on set
uh well he said he said it's because
he's from mexico and he doesn't have
cold or rain in mexico and he loves them
both i don't know but uh he's going to
have to stop doing that he used to do
something on an island
oh it's so cold it was so cool but um
no i mean yeah i i've always thought
he's open
to to um
it took me a while to understand it as
you
anybody you work with it takes you a
while to understand their process and
what they do and how they think and
you know um i had an image of guillermo
as someone who is very
uh controlling in the sense that he
knows what he wants he's this movie is
in his head he you you heard him talk
about it if you talk to him about this
he every time i hear him i go oh my gosh
oh wow that's
uh
but
the truth is he's really open he's open
and
to anything you want to try anything you
want to do and once you realize that
about him uh
it's
it's
i mean as i say i've never it's hard to
think of anybody with those same
qualities that both of those qualities
together it's a but that's that's
guillermo and uh
and and and i could tell from some of
the choices
that he made in the edit
of what takes he used
that he was looking for something a
little different this time
he was looking for something he was
looking for
it's like the only thing that mattered
to him in the scene was was it alive
what
was it
two human beings
living talking and living their life
in front of him on the screen
wow interesting um
you've said in a q a that you loved it
was great fun to play somebody who gets
what they want
can you talk about this character
did it feel different from perhaps
others i mean this is a man of great
wealth and the first time we see him i
had a feeling of terror i felt like he
had capacity to be very cruel or or i
wasn't really sure who he was going to
be
well i always thought he was a pretty
sweet guy but um
i i think we all you know as
you know i
most people think they're who me i'm i'm
a wonderful person but right um i love
the fact that he gets what he wants
because it proves that that doesn't mean
anything
most people in this movie get what they
want
uh stanley gets what he wants
and look what it does to him you know
it's really interesting uh some we i
think we a lot of us want the wrong
things
isn't that the the darn truth um
speaking of getting what you want the
first time you read the script did you
have a reaction to the fact that you're
flipping through the pages and you're
like wait where where am i where am i
what was your reaction as an actor
well i trusted guillermo i knew he it uh
i was thrilled when i read it i was
thrilled when i read this guy uh
i i just think it's so interesting to
play somebody who is after one thing
he's after forgiveness that's what he
wants he wants to be forgiven for for an
act he committed years and years ago and
he gets his wish
and look what happens to him it's really
it was a it really an interesting thing
to uh
to do
as an actor did you channel anybody did
you use anybody as an inspiration or did
you just really mainly delve in the
script
well the script is where all of the
clues are i mean that's where every clue
is to to
you as an actor to who you are
it's what you do what you say what
people say about you what how people
respond to you i mean that's really
where the clues are and uh that's that's
kind of where i go and then how much do
you reveal as an actor and how much do
you hold back i mean you're such a
you've been doing this for so long how
do you make that choice of of the
balancing act
well it's it's what who you're talking
to on screen what you're doing um if you
want them to know something or if you
don't want them to know something you
know it's uh that's kind of what you do
uh
sometimes you don't want them to know
something and and
by accident it slips out that you do it
so it's really it's it's it's
again i'll say that it's
for me it's i love watching characters
live their life on the screen nothing
more nothing more i don't want them to
tell me anything i don't want them to
say to me as an audience oh i
i i said i like this person but i really
don't i don't want that uh you know i
want to see people dealing with what's
going on in their lives
i will ask you simple questions you will
answer in short sentences only what you
believe to be absolute truth
absolute truth
i can do that
congratulations on this film you play
both a mentor and a mentalist i'm going
to start with the mental part um
you know your character has this book
that he eventually gives to bradley's
character where it's all the tricks of
the trade the secrets of becoming a
mentalist was that book actually filled
with true things like how much
backstory did you create for yourself
that book was
was a
a code book
wow whoever had done the props i forget
their name at the moment but
it was
it was beautiful document artifact but
they had written in
with drawings
numbers codes the whole thing was in
there
packed with it and so
uh
to have that in my as a resource was
extraordinary
and how much backstory did you create
for your character because he's at a
certain point in his life but you sense
that he's uh you know he's covering up
things by drinking but he's also at
peace in a sense more than any other
character i think in the film with where
he's at so how much of a backstory did
you create and how much of a mentalist
are you now as a result of researching
this character
well i love that you s you mentioned
that he's at peace um and i i think pete
is and and xena
for the most part are these characters
who are at peace with their life they're
in the carnal they've been doing this
for a long time obviously they
they were a lot more successful they
were in the you know
on the circuit and making you know
quite a career for themselves and
they're sort of at the end of he's at
the end definitely of his is his time
um but the fact that he is at peace
is significant in the film because here
is a place
in a world which is fraught with danger
and
uh fantasticness and
lots of transient and you know it's a
really gritty rough place but
they live in a little house with
in the film um
for the moment where the
when the carnival's there
and they offer bradley's character
standing carlisle a potential family so
i think that's uh it's great that you
mentioned
the piece of pete yeah um
i wouldn't say that uh i'm a mentalist
uh
you know it's uh
no i
that's a particular skill i think
that you have to you hone and practice
over many many many years and uh and you
do need a code book
yeah well in a sense an actor is a
mentalist in a way because you're always
if you're a great actor you're reading
another character and processing and
hopefully taking that person in i want
to ask you you sort of led me into one
of my questions when you were talking
about that world first time working with
guillermo del toro he really created
that world of the carnival for you to
sort of live in can you talk about that
aspect of it how it allowed you to
immerse yourself in that world was it
claustrophobic because you're kind of
behind you know did it feel
claustrophobic in a sense
he really did set it up for you in a way
that you could just exist in that world
can you talk about that and gear the
guillermo a factor of it all well you
arrive on the set and it's not really
your set you're arriving at a carnival
wow
yes wow uh it it could have can
stay there throughout however long and
people from the neighboring towns would
come there and they could go to the
carnival
because it was
it was real i don't know the word to
describe it with the
the the the we are out in the weather it
was probably the size of a football
field that they built this whole thing
nothing uh artificial about it
so as as an actor you put on your your
wardrobe that is you know meticulously
designed and and researched
yeah and you walk into the world and
there it is everywhere you look yeah
there's equipment there's camera
equipment thing but
the thing that you were most overwhelmed
with and most uh
uh
was the fact that here you are walking
in mud
it's raining you're lying in straw
the tents are the same it's it was just
uh and and that's guillermo's genius of
and also the production
company and the production designers to
accomplish that extraordinary i'm gonna
ask end with kind of an existential
question in a sense but one of the
biggest themes of this film is a person
finding out who they truly are i'm
wondering when you are an actor
does that bring you closer to who you
really are do you think or because
you're playing a character are you
further away because you're you're
playing these characters well it's
always a
a challenge to just discover to discover
who the character is
there may be similarities you have
certain
uh um
things that you might identify with uh
that might ring a bell about oh yes i
but for the most part it's the
request is to discover who the character
is
and
you know that's uh
uh it's probably a lot easier than um
stanton carlisle's journey to learn out
who to learn who he was which he
eventually comes to to reckon with this
out who actually he is and what he needs
in the world but
um
yeah
that's one of the
i would say fun but challenging but also
exciting things about doing this is you
get to inhabit or guess or at least
create
something else you know
another person
you